what if you didn't wash your hair for a  year  at first this might have some benefits  for your scalp giving you thicker and  more voluminous hair but after a couple  of weeks your dew might start to smell a  bit funky that's because your hair traps  moisture which allows bacteria to build  up on your scalp so after a month your  hair might smell sour and your scalp  could be itchy as the months went on  more bacteria would accumulate on your  scalp and clog up your hair follicles  this could lead to unwanted pimples hair  loss and possibly no friends  but everyone's hair is different some  people might only need to wash their  hair once a month while others need it  every couple of days it's all about  listening to your scalp if it feels  dirty or is starting to get itchy you  should probably give it a wash so have  you ever wondered